de la colère mais surtout un appel au
secours pour ces milliers de migrants
demandeurs d'asile sans abri a bloqué à
lesbos
ils réclament leur départ de cette île
grecque où des incendies gigantesques
ont détruit ces derniers jours le camps
sordides de morgat le plus grand
d'europe
j'ai cinq enfants et nous vivons ici
dans de mauvaises conditions parce que
la nuit il fait très froid et nous
n'avons rien tous mes biens ont brûlé
j'ai très peur j'ai très peur ici à
marjah je fais des crises d angoisse
tout le temps je suis dans une mauvaise
situation et mes enfants sont tous petit
et ils sont souvent malades nous avons
besoin dead des incendies qui ont
détruit la jungle de morgat où habitait
près de 12000 700 personnes soit quatre
fois plus que sa capacité initiale
les flammes ont laissés dans la rue de
nombreuses familles dont 4000 enfants
face à ce drame la grèce a lancé un cri
d'alarmé lieux pour venir en aide à ces
personnes et notamment aux mineurs
dix pays de l'union européenne vont donc
accueillir quelques 400 migrants mineurs
non accompagnés à la suite des
discussions entre les états membres de
l'union européenne
dix étapes participeront avec nous à la
re localisation des mineurs non
accompagnés
mais d'après ce que je sais nous sommes
toujours en discussion avec d'autres
états membres
fortis film days marre de ces 400
mineurs seront accueillis par la france
et l'allemagne
selon nos informations l'allemagne et la
france accueilleront chacune entre 100
et 150 mineurs sous d'autres formes
c'est un drame qui relance le débat sur
l'accueil des demandeurs d'asile en
europe
passer des paroles aux actes voilà
l'exhortation du gouvernement grec à ses
partenaires européens lors du sommet
euro med 7 qui se tient encore cette
semaine pour répondre à la crise
migratoire
la commission européenne doit présenter
à la fin du mois une proposition très
attendu et plusieurs fois repoussé d'un
nouveau pacte sur la migration et
d'asile
le troisième point de la proposition
serait un système de solidarité
permanente et efficace pour assumer les
responsabilités en matière d'asile non
seulement entre les quelques états
membres à l'entrée de l'union européenne
où les quelques états membres comme
l'allemagne qui font exception
nous avons besoin d'une véritable
solidarité dans notre politique
migratoire
pour sa part le gouvernement grec peine
à se courir ces migrants et appelle les
autorités locales à trouver une solution
rapide pour héberger les sans abri la
protection civile grecque a déclaré
l'état d'urgence pour quatre mois à
lesbos forte de 85 mille habitants et
principale porte d'entrée des migrants
en grèce en raison de sa proximité avec
la turquie